a car has exploded in the u.s city of
nashville
and what police there say they believe
was an intentional
act it happened earlier this morning
federal authorities including the fbi
are now investigating and at least three
people have been
taken to hospital and let's get the
latest now from sky's melena
besselinovich
malena just bring us up to date with the
latest thankfully people will be
absolutely gobsmacked that there were
only three injuries given the scale of
the explosion and the great news is that
out of those three people they're not
in critical condition other than that
the police have now cordoned off large
parts of central
nashville and as you mentioned there not
only
local but also federal agencies are
involved in this investigation
including the fbi earlier on the police
said they do believe that this
was an intentional act here's what the
police spokesman said in a press
conference
before six o'clock this morning central
precinct officers received a call
of a shots fired on 2nd avenue north
when the officers responded they saw no
immediate evidence of shots fired
but they did encounter a suspicious
vehicle and rv
that was parked in front of the at t
building at 166
second avenue north the officers
had calls to ask for the hazardous
devices unit our bomb squad to respond
as the hazardous devices unit was
responding
to the downtown area the rv
exploded at 6 30 this morning we do
believe this to have been
an intentional act significant damage
has been done
to the infrastructure there on second
avenue north
and this does appear to have been a very
powerful explosion
you could see from scenes that shattered
glass was sent up flying you could see
black smoke
billowing from the scene of the
explosion and local media spoke to a man
who lives nearby who said that this
blast blew away
all of the windows in his home and that
his entire building
shook now it took place in what is a
touristy part
of nashville there's lots of restaurants
and bars there but
of course that early on christmas
morning thankfully
there weren't many people around the
priority now for the police is to make
sure that anyone who was in the area
when this explosion happened is
accounted for
and also that the fire which is still
raging really in certain parts of it
is contained but this is still very much
a developing situation in an ongoing
live investigation neil melania thank
you